this is gold stars and pan this wasn't
anything what I thought it was the the
picture before I you know cuz I'll say
like bag and see the pictures of the
next one so this is gonna be like
something really crazy uh it was a
picture of the Lich I'm there and I'm
thinking like oh my God he's back and
then that's like the first second and
then the little boy wakes up and it's
like oh yeah that's right it was just a
dreamy as having so it's mostly about
his day and him going to school he gets
me fun of a little bit there's all these
people watching him waiting for him to
like you know snap and go back to his
you know lychee ways uh but he seems to
be okay and then these two people come
the original king of Ooo who uh I try to
remember like cuz we saw him I care for
if he did anything like Superbad I just
remember he's bad news like you just
don't want him around and people's
especially is like no get the hell out
of here you you know phony you fake I
mean just like get super super pissed
just at the mention of its name so you
know this guy's not good Louis during a
tree trunks is yeah the wedding yeah um
so but he has this idea to teach him how
to dance which is just wiggling his
belly and it makes people laugh so much
that they rob them and yeah he gets a
gold star though so he sees it's okay
and it's kind of almost like this
Pinocchio story with like you know the
Fox McKitrick iam and stuff and that
just he turns back into the lecture a
little bit just like you know I will
give you a cold star thank you my
teachers wha he goes back to being a
little boy and uh we have no idea what's
gonna happen now so it's like I guess
it's a little bit like what's expecting
like at the end but yeah I just
completely forgot I'm like oh yeah he's
like a little kid again um and
everyone's cautious and they think it's
okay but yeah they're sort of I guess a
typical adventure time uh format there's
just a ton of foreboding doom everywhere
it's a you got the comet and that
you have you know the Lich can snap at
any point uh so yeah it's uh it's just
at first I was kind of like oh this is
gonna be the episode just this little
kid going around teehee how I can take
advantage of and stuff but it just so
catches you off-guard when he suddenly
does turn into that monster again it
kind of very quickly puts you in
uncomfortable place again I sort of like
just when everything goes black you know
before this there was nothing before
nothing that were monsters you know
thank you my teachers and I'll give you
a gold star you know I like all that I
like it
just how quickly it can make you feel
like uh you know like you're in a bad
presence again um but it's okay cuz you
can still do the belly dance and make
the kids laugh and yeah we'll see what
happens
now the truffle shuffle - the truffle
shuffle yes um is that what they called
it from Goonies valid only at the Chavo
Chavo do the truffle shuffle wanna do it
so um yes there it is um I did it's fine
it's a clever way of showing that like
you know she could still happen you know
in this body with this little kid and
stuff um and yeah I can't think of too
much else to say about it outside via
cavity is what it is unless there's
unless you saw something good I'm
missing whoa well I okay I need to see
this because I've been said and so long
it's been like a week
I hate Disney you brought a Pinocchio so
I say no cuz I was a story just the
general story doesn't have to be
Pinocchio I mean the Disney web okay oh
yeah whatever it's been you know it's
been a week hey you no no no that's
actually really how I saw it it really
reminded me of the whole Disney it's the
whole you know yeah don't worry
come with me um actually not being a fan
of tree trunks um because if you
remember choose about to break up with
mr. pig because nothing was going right
then Ulsan they had a baby okay Sifl
makes every
yeah and it's like the most is I have a
really technically baby it's like the
most awful terrible being in a baby but
if you notice their technique they're
kind of terrible parents yeah we're
gonna go on a date we'll leave you alone
because your education on the fridge and
show how smart you are an apple but
they're not even like being a parent you
know you kind of want to check up on
your kid you know talk to your teachers
how are they doing hey if Bri came home
with an A I wouldn't just be like good
job I'm never gonna communicate with
anyone ever again it's like no you're
doing a good job I still want to find
out what's going on and all that stuff
you know and to me it's like their
terrible parent oh yeah um but he's a
happy kid so they're not terrible in
this they're not like they're neglectful
if anything hmm you know but they treat
him well and they are taking care of him
and everything and it shows how quickly
someone can go from being happy to being
completely mistreated and misused and
taking down the completely wrong path mm
you know because of these two you know
jerks that are taking advantage of him
he went from this happy kid happy kid
that didn't care that people were even
laughing at him to evil again mm-hmm and
you know if you look at most kids that
are bullied or picked on what happens
you go down that path and sometimes the
kids you know get stronger and fight
against it or those kids turn into bad
kids yeah there's always like I feel
like anyone that does get like bullied
or made fun of or whatever it's like
you're right there's kind of those two
paths you're either gonna be like
extremely kind of legs of stronger
resourceful and nice and why don't watch
me are people that way cuz I hurt so I'm
yet you know I can't do that or it goes
the opposite where it's like you can
still be creative and stuff but you're
gonna be like an extreme angry well this
is what I went through this is all I
know so I'm just gonna spread that to
others that's how the world works and
that's I was treating me so yeah that is
kind of interesting how just that little
beginning can sort of split off these
two ads um you know in hindsight it
really doesn't make sense to give him
two tree trunks and mr. pig what it made
more sense
give it a like Princess Bubblegum you
know she's like the scientist she keeps
on top of everything it she likes to
give an eye and everything but it make
more sense to give her I completely
remember when they dropped him off on
the gas fuck
I think it's just like hey you know
they're they're relatively harmless they
should be okay but maybe that is that
maybe they feel because there always has
been kind of that controversy with
bubblegum about her like having too much
power anybody doesn't know if she should
have that much power that's always kind
of talk so maybe that kind of makes
sense and with with tree trunks and mr.
pig even though they're not could be the
best parents they're most likely not
gonna be use that power at the very
least I'm not gonna know how to abuse
that power yeah it's so you know they're
gonna be you know we arm was it's more
the whole ignorant is bliss yeah to an
extent and that's kind of how I see tree
trunks and mr. pig it's kinda that all
they're very ignorant to what's going on
they don't even realize what they have
there so there's no fear of them tapping
into it or even kind of bringing it out
even like when he hands all the riches
and the gold and silver ore to gal
that's playing my teachers OH I said
like you're not gonna ask for more
they're not gonna try and get a profit
out of it or try to you know utilize it
to get all these riches they're just
nice and just never questioned it again
you know there's not smart enough for
that or mean enough I don't know um but
yeah so still don't know that's the best
choice but at least it makes a little
bit more sense in hindsight and I mean
you had the nail on the head like I love
Ron Perlman's voice like he has like
just the best like deep I don't mess
with me I will yeah like he does the
best voice and him as the Lich is so
good and yeah when that when those eyes
turn green and everything and he starts
talking into the Lich it's like well and
what I liked what I liked about Ron
Perlman's voice is that it's a voice
some people you just recognize their
voice right away you're like Christopher
Lee or something like that you know
that's Christopher Lee and you get it uh
but with Ron Perlman it kind of takes
you a bit I mean it's not that it's not
distinct but it's not so distinct that
it's distracting
ya know I mean you can
see the character ease if you saw him
the oh yeah romp Romo because that's
like the world's most distinct for yes
you know but but just hearing the voice
it's like he can kind of become these
other characters you know he can be you
know a good strong main character he can
be like a horrifying terrible villain
you know I'm both can really work his
voice like you brought it Christopher
Lee and I like Christopher Lee I like
his Dracula work and her but he mainly
plays villains and that's kind of like
what he's really good at and that's what
his voice is really really almost like a
tune for but like Ron Perlman has a very
commanding voice yeah like when he talks
you're kind of supposed to listen and he
can play a good guy or a bad guy and
that voice just kind of works in either
role yeah you know and that's one reason
why when he talks is the Lich's just
like I don't feel comfortable right now
yeah I mean it's just like this what is
so immediate that's what I like about I
mean just immediately from this very
cutesy episodes bright colors and mostly
a little kid talking so just to
immediate fear yeah I love the way they
just do that jump but they just change
the atmosphere so quickly yeah um no I
thought they did that very one I thought
even though you know it's a fine episode
that sort of made the putting up with
the cutesy wutesy stuff throughout the
majority of it totally worth it cuz then
when it does do that shift you're like
oh she yeah and I thought that was both
very effective and kind of funny yeah
you know that through most as you're
watching you know this cutesy stuff and
it just suddenly boom you know in this
dark place um one thing I have to say
and it always drives me nuts in TV shows
and movies when they do it when so and
overhear something they're like oh wait
what did you hear it's like why would
you answer that and I love how to
Toronto what did you hear it doesn't
matter it's all bad like what what did
you hear take care of him
hahaha what did you hear why would you
tell them what you heard and would they
believe you I am a little curious what
it's like you know cuz I kind of forgot
about the king of until he showed my oh
yeah that's right the wedding and stuff
like that and it just kind of made me
even more interested like yeah what what
is his connection to bubble guy is it
really father/daughter or is it more
because it looked like she kind of came
from that pink Suzy stuff or whatever
and it's like did he somehow create that
or father that so I'm really curious to
see you like what the connection is even
there maybe there isn't one maybe four
maybe he adopted her maybe she almost
adopted him in a sense like me she came
across like you know okay I have to
blend in somehow in a position of power
and this will work you knows guys an
idiot um so I'm like but she also has
this immense hatred for him so I'm like
really really curious uh what the story
is behind that I take amorous like an
evangelist or someone along those lines
it kind of comes in as like pushed out a
lake
look at me I am the king of Ooo
like he seems to be a complete con man
that's the way I take him and I don't
apologize to evangelists so it's like he
seems to be just a complete con men like
everything he's doing is kind of like
just to get more money or get more fame
or get more power and that's why I think
PB hates him so much PB worked her ass
off to get to where she is bro for all
we know maybe she was originally queen
and then he came in fooled everyone to
think he's king so they demoted her
difference maybe she actually was like
in this huge like even bigger position
of power I mean I guess it's pretty much
the same but like even the title
reflected in that I'm like he came about
and like you know I just convinced them
all that he's the king it's like oh
that's okay you can still be princess
and then like she got rid of him or
whatever that actually makes a lot of
sense to like to an extent it's that
whole thing of like you know PB built
the Candy Kingdom built the people and
then someone else just kind of coming
into that edit and I'm the key yeah he
kind of seems like the con artist type
who would do then the people seem dumb
enough to fall for it so yeah it could
be
one of those things where it's like me
that'd be a really funny backstory
actually that is what happened um so ya
know I'm really curious what that is so
um yeah - uh all the even chemical news
sites watching um
I know nothing about your religion so I
can't count it on it almost summer-like
Christian for the most part now okay and
when I say that it's like stretching it
yes obviously it's not like the most
common ones but for the most part it
kind of goes down those lines but
they're kind of bizarre isn't all
religion just Christianity no no I think
you're wrong
I mean like Satanists really wouldn't be
that's still technically from
Christianity now actually actually
technically fakeness only use the word
Satan as a means of kind of like getting
a reaction you don't actually worship
your boy didn't know Alec does all
religions being one it's both profound
and closed-minded okay I'll accept that
but will you accept a new car I have no
ending